costaud que j'arrive à fable de charge
complètement je me sens protégée mais ça
insécurité et je me sens libre
les cris de la baie james ont
profondément attachés à leur territoire
des rivières majestueuse des forêts à
perte de vue ils se sont battus pendant
30 ans devant les tribunaux contre les
coupes à blanc des forestières
[Musique]
roméo saganash chasser loutard de tous
les printemps près de waswanipi un
printemps qui arrive et y avait rien la
forêt tatatata m'a coupé c'est un choc
au nom d'une île la cour donne raison
aux cris le régime forestier québécois
violer leurs droits le jugement force
québec a négocié le gouvernement du
québec et les click on s'entassait
sellers poursuites judiciaires de
plusieurs milliards de dollars en tant
qu'économiste ps et bernard landry a
très bien compris qu'ils avaient une
industrie entière qui était en fait un
nouveau café étant les principaux
architectes de l'entente nous fassions
le pays des bluffs quand l'entente de
principe et signé à l'assemblée
nationale le grand chef lui demande
juste avant de prendre la parole
d'écrire une phrase en français dans son
discours et j'ai créé aujourd'hui nous
enterrons la hache de guerre nous
faisons la paix des braves et ça restait
cette entente a juste permis
ça soit normal pour un peuple autochtone
de vouloir une autonomie de pouvoir
décider du destin de son territoire et
du développement des ressources des
droits
l'ecri abandonne des poursuites de 8
milliards et accepte qu'hydro-québec
construisent une nouvelle centrale en
dérivant la rue père une des plus
grandes rivières au monde c'est un
immense sacrifice qui divise les cris en
échange québec promet 4 milliards sur
cinquante ans ait des milliers d'emplois
pour ce propriétaire d'un café at his à
siby la paix des braves est un gros
chèque de bien-être social qui touche
l'instinct de survie des cris
et des mamies le monstre dont par
l'homme d'affaires c'est la bureaucratie
cris qui ne cesse de grossir
éducation santé services sociaux système
de justice police conseil de bande si
services fournissent 80% des emplois sur
le territoire et contribuerait à creuser
l'écart entre riches et pauvres
c'est ce que lorsque tu crées une norme
furent cassés dans une société créée une
classe de personnes qui sont mieux
nantis que notre donc positif oui et du
travail il travaille mais c'est à quel
coût ça coûtait quoi pour dehors on
pense qu'on est riche je sais pas qu'on
est riche salaire qu'on est riche mais
je suis pas sûr parce que c'est super
talent que la culture est où ta richesse
acquise au mieux cache avec abandonné
ses études en 2002 pour militer contre
l'entente vingt ans plus tard
ces inquiétudes se sont concrétisées
pour moi la paix des braves ça veut dire
la meurtre de deux rivières c'était
vraiment pas nécessaire puis ç'a
beaucoup blessé une autre génération
les cris sont ils aujourd'hui plus
autonome dans la gestion de la forêt
coupe ton encore trop d'arbres selon moi
oui mais l'objectif ce avec la paix des
braves est de donner la parole à ceux et
celles qui vivent sur le territoire de
nous dire où s'il pourra voir l'avenir
forestière où peut-on couper les trappes
en ont pas le choix puis ils se font
passer brillamment des communautés je
pense que même si ce n'est les trappeurs
il ya une route qui a passé à travailler
pour une des mines puis à personne qui
consulte et les trappeurs et c'est aussi
un exemple d'assimilation parce que
l'homme est notre gouvernement traite
notre peuple la même façon que
l'événement québec près d'herat nous
avons traité un email
les artisans de la paix des braves
longtemps à donner on crée un poids
politique qui force les gouvernements à
les traités en égaux en les opposant
cette autonomie n'ya pas servir mieux
protéger le territoire des cris ni leur
mode de vie traditionnel
[Applaudissements]